Pete Weber he's the voice of the
Nashville Predators he's been doing that
since 1998 Pete kind enough to join us
after I'm sure nice long night there
Pete thanks for joining us
how's morale in Nashville you know it's
so down I don't know what we're going to
do to get people happy again this is
going to be a real challenge then but by
god I'm glad to have that challenge
right now if I told you two months ago
this was going to happen you would have
said what can I have your car keys yeah
I mean this has just been a miraculous
miraculous roll that the team has gotten
on and I guess it's a good idea to have
a coach in charge now it's taken three
different teams for the Stanley Cup slam
how would you summarize what has taken
place here in the land well last month
or so a lot of it now is next man up
because of the injuries the team had
losing Ryan Johansen losing the captain
Mike Fisher and earlier in the playoffs
losing a young kid is not exactly a
household name Kevin Fiala but wasn't
thoroughly in process of becoming one
and then getting guys to step in
Colten systems with a hat-trick last
night Austin Watson a first-round draft
pick from a number of years ago who has
a reengineered role with the team now
adding physicality blocking shots etc so
this has been a team that is simply okay
what's our next task we'll take care of
it and let's think of nothing else other
than that task that's right in front
what I love is hell Nashville has
embraced the Predators and granted
they've been there for two decades but
did they just become an overnight
sensation or how would you describe the
city's affection for this team you know
I think it happened when the founding
owner Craig Leopold put the club up for
sale on Memorial Day just about this
time 2007 and it looked like it was
going to be moved to Hamilton Ontario
therefore shortly for a little bit and
then all of us are getting our homes
ready for sale preparing for a move
perhaps and then a local group of owners
got together bought the team saved it
for Nashville this after a very dramatic
save our team rally at the arena in two
by of that year and since that point in
time well let's go forward to that
following April the club was stripped
down for sales so outstanding players
Paul Kariya they didn't have the money
to offer him another contract so he left
then they traded Thomasville Kuhn who
was the strong goaltender from the start
of the franchise to Florida kimochi
mannan Scott Hartnell to Philadelphia
and then there was an intermission
rather a TV timeout in early all eight
in April and the Predators had to have
that win to make the playoffs the club
did not ask for this the fans just stood
as one with the standing ovation to urge
the team on the Predators responded to
it made the playoffs that year and the
fans have been the driving influence
ever since that time so it's it's not
really one of those overnight success
stories but it's one that was rather
quiet around the country until now he
got a lot of celebrities that show up
you know the whole atmosphere what was
the meaning of the catfish on the ice
lantern
okay that's the answer the big rivalry
of the early years was Detroit there
were so many Michigan people here for
the Nissan and Saturn plants that they
were telling us you know how great
Detroit was all the time and the octopus
tradition that went back to the 50s in
Detroit first at the Olympia Bennett had
now departed Joe Louis Arena throwing an
octopus on the ice because at that point
in time it took eight wins to win the
Stanley Cup
well the Predators wanted to have the
Predators fans wanted to have their own
answer to that and they couldn't think
of any shall we say a version of
something from the sea something from
the river something from a pond
something from a stream that resembled
that and it would be indigenous to
Tennessee other than the catfish and
that's how it happened now some of these
den look like they've been treated
radioactively they're darn thick well
that one last night was pretty pretty
big we're talking to Pete Weber he's the
voice of the Nashville Predators it
feels like America no matter which team
you're facing Ottawa or Pittsburgh is
going to embrace Nashville it's a you
know eight seed worst record of all the
playoff teams going in the atmosphere
they're celebrities on the ice
you know Nashville is a great town so
you get that feeling that this is not
America's Team we've used that before
with other sports but this is a team
that if you're a curiosity seeker you
might be tuning in to watch Nashville
yeah I think so and by the way might I
extend an invitation for you to come
here and do your your show again and I
promise you'll have a much better studio
here than the last time you did one
where are we going to eat though Pete
there's there's hardly any place
basically said but you know something I
bet we can find something what would be
the place I would have because I can't
travel by myself dad to bring the dance
with me right that's not a problem okay
so what we won't go to any chains
obviously we'll have to sample some
barbecue okay uh you and the dinettes
might well like some of the hot chicken
that is big part of the Tennessee
culture here right now and afterwards
well moonshine you're getting a round of
applause on the other side of the glass
with with the moonshine there yeah we
might have to take you up on that beat
hey could we do yeah it's it's been a
great run it's a lot of fun to watch
great atmosphere there and the ride
continues thanks for joining us Pete
thank you for having me on day I briefed
here that's Pete Weber the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience